this is the IBM personal computer it was
the most advanced computing machine ever
created however this isn't a story about
a computer but a story about when a
computer stops working and the man who
created a way to start it all over the
man who invented control-alt-delete
let's get into it
[Music]
hi I'm dr. Dave Bradley but you can call
me dr. Dave back in 1980 I worked on the
IBM personal computer my particular job
on the IBM PC was writing the basic
input/output system even with an elite
team of engineers and designers not
everything goes smoothly when you're
building a computer we had programs that
ran most of the time but when they
failed the only way to reset the system
was turn the power off wait awhile turn
the power back on and it would go
through a very long self-test but the
system might die every 5 to 10 minutes
what he needed was a way to shortcut the
restart process one of the things we
discussed was putting a reset button on
it but if you put it on the system board
there was a chance that you could hit it
by mistake and all your data gets lost
so what we did was came up with a three
key sequence who would reset to this
computer and you couldn't hit by mistake
a single control key a single Alt key
and then all the way over at the right
hand side a single Delete key
when you hit that control-alt-delete
you're deleting everything that you're
working on right now and starting new I
was also able to skip over many of the
tests so instead of taking a minute or
two it was ten or fifteen seconds but it
wasn't a big deal at the time it was
like number 17 on the list of a hundred
different things I had to fix even
though it was built only as a
development tool programmers began
incorporating the feature into their
applications from there it was released
into the wild but didn't immediately
reach pop culture status for years there
was no big deal and then at the 20th
anniversary of the IBM PC that's when
control lawfully became sort of a
cultural like it was as simple as an
easiest way to fix your problem hit
control-alt-delete start all over
despite all this dr. Dave doesn't think
much of this contribution to computing
history I get lots of things with IBM
but all everybody remembers this
control-alt-delete but I'll take that
the fame of control-alt-delete means
that I worked on a very successful
product and I'm very proud of having
been able to do that
[Music]
these paintings they aren't done with
acrylic oil or water color it's got did
it opaque to us Microsoft Excel the
computer program this is a story about
tats well the Microsoft Excel artist
[Music]
what does she wanna put each tattooing
then idea not outside this when tats all
retired he decided he wanted to paint
but there was one problem he was cheap
husband cocking on a ship were chosen to
get Easter Bunny poke all day no sorry
I'll get the rope in the mukou gonna
mean he wasn't named mrs. Dooley
somebody was in it he didn't even want
to pay for an art program so he used
what was already on his computer the soy
yield a Pina colonics
oh yeah see pretty
so how do you paint in Excel the line
tool it's usually used for spreadsheet
graphs that you can make trees with and
the bucket tool it helps with subtle
shading on for example the crest of a
volcano
the Sioux equal 20 unit depth aroma
today stuck in the UL continuity muslim
votaciones saved a yokohama today so
nice in increments Bogue Chitto Teton
Sioux June and conventional braces
empirical yaki
at anaconda Celestia entire package on a
cargo van and a in okinawa karate in for
accessory kit
[Music]
it's a you know Nagaraja
3:19 I know she were very mistaken there
what does he know your name put a hot
pepper in the story today
he got a Miskin Tetris it transcends age
culture and language it's a gamer and
non-gamers game but did you know Tetris
has a Soviet past Tetris is the
brainchild of this man Alexey Pajitnov
Alexey was a computer programmer in
Russia he worked for the Soviet Union at
the Moscow Academy of Sciences Alexey
always had a propensity for math
computers and puzzles it was that
propensity that led him to the creation
of the best video game of all times he
drew inspiration from a little-known
game pentominoes pentominoes was a
puzzle board game in which you had to
fit geometric shapes together Alexey
took the principles from pentominoes
upgraded them and created a computer
game originally only intended for
himself he named the game Tetris for two
reasons it's a combination of tetra the
Greek word meaning for and tennis
Pajitnov favorite sport because Tetris
was created during work hours the Soviet
Union claimed all rights to both Tetris
and all royalties boy
fast forward to nice 96 the rights of
tetris was finally signed over to posit
not tetris taps into our universal need
to create order out of chaos which is
ultimately why it's one of the most
iconic games in history
[Music]
you got you you've got man you've got
you you've got man goodbye you all of
you who thought a AOL was voiced by a
computer now let's set the record
straight I recorded those phrases
welcome you've got mail files done
goodbye
my name is Elwood Edwards and I'm the
voice of you've got mail in 1989 my wife
was a customer service rep for the
company that was about to become America
Online she heard Steve Case talking to
some of the programmers about how fun it
would be to add a voice to the software
I've been an announcer throughout my
entire broadcasting career and she
volunteered me I scribbled those phrases
on a piece of paper and like I say on
the cassette deck I recorded the welcome
you've got mail files done goodbye it
started off as a test just to see if it
would catch on and lo and behold in the
mid 90s it had really caught on and at
one point they said my voice was heard
more than 35 million times a day but the
problem was I was typecast the one thing
I did do was a voice for The Simpsons
you've got leprosy goodbye
being associated with AOL has been
gratifying even today you go on AOL
dot-com I greet you I greet myself
[Music]
when I look at a floppy this today I
look at something that's valuable and
that I use and yet when most people look
at it they'll look at it almost as a
joke floppy disks calm I'm the last man
standing in the floppy disk business
because I basically forgot to get out of
the business in this office we're in a
time warp the manufacturing of the
diskettes is over and so all of the
diskettes that will be made have been
made I'm desperately trying to acquire
as many diskettes as I possibly can all
kinds of disks come flying into our
doors from time to time
commercial recycler will call me up and
say hey I have somewhere between 35 and
50 thousand disks we sort them we run
them through a process to erase the
information once the diskettes are
reformatted and we labeled we're able to
resell them we do sell to the US
government there are a number of
applications that the government has
that call for the use of a floppy disk
the old saw is if it ain't broke don't
fix it most of our business is for
commercial and industrial use whether
they be embroidery machines ATMs
avionics for airplanes so those machines
are still around and they're going to
last for quite a few more years the
floppy disk business will not be around
forever no I won't be around forever
either